die us-Arzneimittelbehörde
FdP bezeichnet es Als Einen Historischen Schritt Zum Ersten mal üBerhaupt Weltweit Ist Eine gentherapie Gegen Krebs Zugelassen Worden
Erst Einmal nur in den usa aber Europa Könnte noch in diesem Jahr Nachziehen die Eigenen Immunzellen Werden Hierbei
Gentechnisch so verändert Dass sie selbst zu tumor Jägern Werden und gegen Den Krebs Kämpfen die Medizin Setzt Große Hoffnung in diese gentherapie
wie hoch die Heilungschancen Sind und ob dies der entscheidende Schritt Im Kampf Gegen Den Krebs Ist Jetzt in Klicks Um science-fiction Herzlich Willkommen
es ist Wirklich absolut Bahn Brechen Konkret geht es Um die therapie Namens
camera des schweizerischen Pharmakonzerns Novartis Ende August hat die us-Arzneimittelbehörde
Fdl diese Gentherapie Auf Dem Amerikanischen Markt Zugelassen Mit ihr sollen Zunächst Einmal Blutkrebs Patienten Also
Leukämie Patienten Aus Den usa unter 25 Jahren Behandelt Werden für die es keine Anderen Chancen Auf Heilung
die sogenannte akute lymphatische leukämie kurz ll in deutschland macht sie fast ein drittel Aller Krebserkrankungen
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen Aus Hierbei
Entarten die Vorläuferzellen der Lymphozyten also der weißen Blutkörperchen
und Vermehren Sich Unkontrolliert die Krankheit Ist Wenn Dann üBerhaupt nur Mit intensiver chemotherapie in Den griff zu Bekommen
medizinerinnen und Mediziner Weltweit Setzen Große Hoffnungen in die gentherapie cumbria in tests Mit
63 Krebskranken Jungen Menschen bei Denen andere Therapien Erfolglos Ausgeschöpft Wurden Habe kümmerer in
83 prozent der fälle Wirkung Gezeigt Innerhalb der Ersten drei Monate
So die Angaben des pharmaherstellers Novartis bei Elfte erkrankten schlug die therapie nicht an bei
29 patienten und patientinnen trat der Blutkrebs Nach Sechs Monaten Wieder Auf Trotzdem Ist dieses Ergebnis
Erfolgreicher Als andere Therapien die Bislang Angewendet Werden die idee Hinter der Kamera Therapie Ist Tatsächlich Beeindruckend
Körpereigene Zellen Eines Blutkrebs Patienten Werden Hierbei so
Umprogrammiert Dass sie selbst Gegen die Krebszellen Kämpfen sie Werden also zu Tumor Jägern Tatsächlich Eine völlig neue Dimension in der Mitte 10
Zunächst Werden Den Betroffenen Bestimmte immunzellen Entnommen die sogenannten T Zellen Im Labor Werden diese Dann
Gentechnisch so verändert Dass sie in der lage Sind Krebszellen zu identifizieren und zu zerstören dies funktioniert Durch
Genmanipulation Hierbei Binden die T-Zellen Einen Bestimmten rezeptor an Ihrer oberfläche
Wodurch sie ein Spezielles
Antigen Auf Den Tumorzellen Erkennen Sie Werden Vervielfacht und dem patienten und patientinnen Dann wieder Als Infusion Verabreicht
Sobald die T-Zellen Krebszellen Identifizieren greifen sie an und
Vervielfältigen sich Wieder absolut Genial Denn so Kann allein Eine Gentechnisch veränderte T zelle tausende Tumorzellen Vernichten
Erwartet Beziffert die Kosten für diese Therapie Auf
475.000 dollar Also Umgerechnet Rund 400.000 euro für Den Hohen Kosten Kommen starke nebenwirkungen die auch Zum tod Führen Können
die Gentherapie Wird Deswegen Zunächst nur in speziellen Us fachzentren Durchgeführt den patienten und Patientinnen
Wird Dann zudem nur Eine Sehr Geringe menge an T-Zellen Verabreicht Um zu üBerprüfen
wie Stark ihre Reaktion Darauf Ist und auch Hier in europa stehen die Chancen Gut Dass diese Gen therapie
Zugelassen Wird Darüber zu Entscheiden hat die europäische arzneimittelagentur ema und ihr Liegen Schon anträge Dazu vor Experten und expertinnen
Hoffen Dass Tausende Schwer Kranke Menschen Bald Davon profitieren Können bei Allen Bedenken Gegen die in therapie manche
medizinerinnen und Mediziner Sprechen Tatsächlich Schon von Einer Neuen äRa der leukämie Behandlung Dieses
Faszinierende prinzip der so produzierten tumor Jäger soll möglichst Bald Auch Auf andere arten von Krebs üBertragen Werden Aufgerüstet immunzellen
Könnten Dann Auch Tumorzellen in Brust- Lungen- Oder
Bauchspeicheldrüse Bekämpfen doch Dies Ist Leichter Gesagt Als Getan das problem Hierbei die T Zellen Haben es viel schwerer solche festen Tumoren zu erreichen
Zudem Ist das milieu in diesen Bereichen des Körpers Ungünstig für sie wenn es hier fortschritte gibt oder komplikationen
Hierbei clixoom hat Sich Euch Natürlich Dazu Auf dem Laufenden Wenn er Kein video zum thema noch zu Allen Anderen Dem Verpassen Wollt Dann Wird
mir ja ein Aber Aufs Auge und Vergesst Nicht den
die glocke Hier geht es Weiter Mit Krebs mit smartphone
Diagnostizieren soll Funktionieren Wie Klickt Auf das video Damit ihr Nicht Um stärkt also Ansonsten Bis Dann
Bleibt Dran